et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois patriat bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes sénateur de
la côte-d'or président du groupe r des
pays ici au sénat c'est le groupe qui
regroupe les sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour stéphane bern est
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france on va
évidemment longuement revenir sur ces
régionales avec vous françois patriat et
sur les enseignements de ce premier tour
notamment pour la majorité
présidentielle qui est dans l'incapacité
clairement de remporter une région même
pas d'être faiseur de roi finalement
dans les régions est ce que c'est
clairement l'échec de l'implantation
locale de la république en marche bien
alors il ya deux façons de voir les
choses
soit je peux faut à faire du faux
triomphalisme vous dire nous étions rien
et nous allons avoir
j'espère dix élus rebond gones franche
comté nous n'avions pas bon je vais pas
vous faire c'est airlines cette musique
là nous sommes en deçà des espérances
que nous avions pension offert entre
case 17%
je vous le dis pour la bourgogne franche
comté faisons doses pour pratiquement 12
ces trois points deux mois après ce père
et ça tient tous les facteurs qu'on a
déjà évoqué évidemment on l'a dit
l'abstention a dit ensuite le fait que
le front national diminue ce qui fait
que les partis classiques qui rêve de
redevenir partie de la sic en france
remonte un peu monsieur platret fait le
jeu prend des voix au rassemblement
national puisqu'il s'est allié à debout
la france
madame du fait signe son score mais dans
le même temps le fait de la peur du
front national l'a fait monter en même
temps nous baissons mais je dis que je
dois dire que moi changer tout ça
gâcherait précisément sur la journée
nationalement nationale on va revenir
sur le captage de vote les gens de
là-bas
de gagner une région qui n'est ni même
d'être ardue le pansage dans un second
tour qui peut penser aujourd'hui qu'un
mouvement né il ya quatre ans est en
mesure de gagner les régions le parti
socialiste pour gagner la région
bourgogne il a mis 20 en 2020 en 30 ans
avec application porno mais je veux dire
que un parti qui n'a pas de
l'implantation locale qui n'a pas de
réseau qui n'a pas d'élus locaux qui n'a
pas d'élus locaux
nous n'avons pas des locaux nous un qui
sait les premières élections
départementales et régionales que nous
avons depuis le quinquennal monsieur
macro et venait même si pas d'élus
locaux parce que vous avez raté les
municipales les mini lavier cinq ans
pour pour la créer cette implantation en
tout cas il nous avoue connaissez vous
un parti à parti fût-il jeudi futile
présidentielle qui en quatre ans ou 5
ans réussit une implantation une
implantation
je me souviendrai parti socialiste
auquel j'ai participé leur congrès
d'epinay ses 10 ans il faut des années
ans mais il ya quand même il ya quand
même la socialiste avant sauf que ici en
l'occurrence on a l'impression de ne pas
assister ne pas même assisté à l'esc is
alain début d'implantation alors j'y
vais vous donner un peu notre
explication je pense je pense que nos
électeurs qui sont et de droite et de
gauche ni de droite ni de gauche votent
différemment selon les élections des
élections par exemple ils voteront
emmanuel macron je pense que le solde
emmanuel macron et bien au delà de
confier aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est
supérieur à 23 mais parmi ces 23 il ya
des gens qui disent ben moi j'ai eu bien
au président ou plutôt j'étais plutôt de
droite avant mais il a beau bilan ou de
gauche c'est vrai aussi en bonbonnes je
le dis par ici écoutez moi je moi j'ai
voté macron je voterai macron mais là ce
que fait tel ou tel président de tel ou
tel président j à des rouges et des
réseaux à côté de moi donc il ya ça qui
joue qui est surtout revenu sur la prime
aux sortants mais est-ce que c'est pas
la preuve qu'aujourd'hui la république
en marche elle ne tient que par la
personnalité des manuels mac ou non non
parce que non parce que d'abord je pense
qu emmanuel macron sera réélu
exportations se poursuit
c'est poursuivra mais dans la la pelouse
à paris vous surtout au delà des mais la
prime au sortant nommé pensez-y ou s'il
a aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
devait se passer si le front national
n'avait pas baissé je me réjouis
aujourd'hui on allait on s'achemine tout
droit et c'est le cas pour les
cantonales vers deuxième tour sortant et
rennes caen et rennes c'est partout
comme ça et la prime aux sortants et là
je veux beaucoup
cette fois ci que les sortants ont été
les seuls à pouvoir faire campagne
ça c'est mal c'est la numératie la
campagne je vois bien les présidents et
présidentes de région chez moi elle a
fait campagne de pub depuis un an
pourquoi parce qu'en plus ils pouvaient
utiliser entendait utiliser l'argent de
l'état les contrats de plan les plans de
relance sont allés distribuer je vois
que son talent et même à dijon faire un
contrat de relance entre la région et
l'agglo il ya trois semaines il ya trois
semaines sont évités les élus nationaux
d'ailleurs à côté là pour leur notoriété
comment voulez vous alors que nous
lançons nouveau candidat à didier
turenne demi thuriau maire de nevers n'a
pas la notoriété en région bourgogne
franche comté qui que ce soit à côté
il part en campagne comment on a fait du
réseau social bien entendu on a fait de
l'entretoise années dont denys qui
étaient candidats qui ont de la
notoriété ils ont échangé ces méthodes
non mais on va revenir un jeu sur un
vélo font chanter mais nationalement il
n'y avait pas que des dames edna de
notoriété il y avait les niçois étaient
tous ceux qui lui sont faits plutôt des
bons de moins d'europe ce qui était tête
de liste ont plutôt fait pendant deux
ans ils ont été éliminés
dpd de ligne j'ai dit tête de liste me
le rend bien le match et si les 1020
très précises qui n'est pas un ministre
c'est dire que dans l'humour en
permanence tati bien c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie en d'état il secrétaire
d'état mes parents où il y avait marc
fesneau
madame darrieussecq et on fait des bons
scores en tout cas qui sont moins moins
élevés que ce qu'ils espéraient enfin
voila mais c'est sûr non je ne pense pas
parce que d'abord ce sont des îles
locaux qui luttent et à planter tdcc
soleil marc chesneau madame darrieussecq
sont des locaux qui ont des réseaux qui
sont implantés depuis longtemps et
beaucoup plus longtemps donc qu'il avait
une notoriété et j'allais dire à une
clientèle des réseaux autour d'eux
qu'est-ce qu'on fait l'arrivée avec le
mouvement la république en marche faut
il faut arrêter il faut foule
transformer l'élargir le faire
disparaître
d'abord ce n'est pas un parti j'ai
milité pendant l'histoire les instants
de la partie
le mouvement donne je vous dis comme ça
donc la différence ce mouvement est un
mouvement qui est à mon avis trop
virtuel on est trop dans l'antre soit
les gens on n'a pas des militants on a
des clippers des gens qui disent moi je
vote macron jogging pour mâcon je trouve
que si bien j'aime bien macron
le verra l'année prochaine je vous dis
je vous déconnecte totalement il ne faut
donner aucune portée nationale à ces
scrutins locaux
je les soudures ont dit par le passé n'a
pas eu un message de la part des
français
qui ont quand même sanctionner les
membres de la majorité présidentielle
qui se sont abstenus est ce que le
président de la république peut se
permettre dans longtemps que ce message
de simplement dire c'est un scrutin
local d'abord d'amo d'abord d'aller
d'abord écouté la sanction relativisons
là moi je suis lucide je suis j'ai de
l'humilité un peu bien vissé scrutin je
reconnais que pour nous c'est un échec
mais je ne suis pas dans le
triomphalisme les autres en face que
quand on est élu quand je vois qu'un
président de région ne citerai pas à
60000 voit aujourd'hui 68 voix un pur
prêtre élu demain que madame buffet je
prends l'exemple ci peut faire du
triomphalisme savez combien la fesse de
voix puis 8 % des inscrits 8 % de
mécontents tout son corps des deux
français sur trois missions pour tout le
monde on ne peut pas dire que ce soit
j'allais dire une défaite de la majorité
une victoire des autres franchement
c'est vrai c'est assez pour nous un
recul par rapport à ce que nous
espérions
ça n'est pas le génial le socle que nous
voudrions avoir dans le même temps je
dis je le détache totalement parce que
dit sanctions moi je constate qu'il ya
un vote sanction par rapport au
gouvernement je vous dis y'a un vote de
non adhésion d'abord à la politique pour
des tas de raisons qu'on pourra évoquer
aujourd'hui parce que ces élections
maintenant à vous et vous connaissez ma
position 1 2 puis 2 depuis deux ans
faire des élections maintenant
le baccalauréat la fin du col ville
début des vacances la femme d'un jean a
les hommes politiques et notamment les
hommes politiques disent ils
la majorité sénatoriale de droite à
droite avait fait un casus belli de la
tenue des élections maintenant
mais j'entends bien mais on voit bien
que c'est cette pression qui
souvenez-vous qu'il était le discours du
président du sénat la démocratie doit
respirer ou sentimentale a vraiment
respirer
je pense qu'une respiration qui peuvent
y d'un éco prêt à dakar du poumon qu'à
fonctionner vous avez donc bon c'est pas
avant mais ça n'est pas ne restons parce
que si on n'avait pas fait maintenant on
nous l'aurait reproché aussi ce que je
veux dire c'est que il faut éviter de
tirer des enseignements nationaux de
cette élection qui est une élection et
wendel en change rien pas de remaniement
alors d'abord le remaniement voici vous
si vous connaissez des ministres qui ont
défailli vous me dites moi j'en connais
pas beaucoup
je ne connais pas un
pour changer les résultats de six
ministres
c'est la tradition quand même en général
quand vous ratez une attaque une
élection intermédiaire et c'est le cas
excuser moi d'insister avec la baisse
générale il ya les ajustements a minima
ont fait vous des savoirs suis
absolument pas traditionalistes
absolument pas manger rien non c'est pas
change rien mais je pense que les
français jugeront de l'année prochaine
d'action du gouvernement
la juge pas de l'action du gouvernement
il ne comprenez rien aux élections ils
savaient pas la différence entre la
région et le département
ils savaient pas qu'ils étaient les
têtes de liste ils arrivent dans les
bureaux j ajoute que pour ce qui me
concerne c'est moi presque un quart de
la population n'a pas reçu les documents
savait même pas qui était il ya des gens
qui n'ont pas eu donc voilà c'est vrai
c'est un échec pour ce qui nous concerne
n'en tirons pas d'autre conclusion on va
en parler mais juge veut revenir sur ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure à la
question stéphane sur sur votre
mouvement vous avez dit aujourd'hui il
ya un problème on est en partie de
cliqueurs est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
ya un problème aujourd'hui avec le
mouvement la république en marché qui a
un problème avec la direction du
mouvement et notamment extremis l'as
bari mais bon je permettrai jamais de
mettre en cause mes amis lui de moins en
moins des 2 lan kwai encore moi
globalement un mouvement auquel
j'appartiens et qui ce qui est là pour
un mouvement de la rigueur c'est vrai
nom mais à partir du moment où le chef
de l'état a voulu que ne soit pas un
parti voit bien que la société
aujourd'hui qu'est numérisés fonctionne
différemment c'est vrai je vous lis dans
cette dans cette campagne électorale et
10% des marcheurs se sont mobilisés les
autres il se sent pas mobile et dans les
campagnes électorales ils disent moi je
suis pour ma part je soutiens macron
mais de là à l'est me demander d'aller
coller des affiches à les distribuer
d'avoir des réunions non je le sens qui
est un problème c'est la nature du
mouvement c'est pas un problème c'est la
nature du mouvement qui est comme ça il
faut en tenir compte
je pense qu'il faut passer maintenant à
la vitesse au dessus je crois que nous
devons à voir si nous devons avoir un
mouvement est pas un parti un mouvement
qui soit celui de la majorité
présidentielle que l' il faut rassembler
aujourd'hui dans un mouvement ils se
mobiliseront la laïcité mobiliseront je
sais pas ce que la savait l'élection
présidentielle et devenu depuis des
années les scion mère celle qui
conditionnent tout ils les gens et
considère maintenant avec le
la version du calendrier quand on a voté
pour le président de la voter pour tout
le monde c'est fini il a pris derrière
les voilà il pense comme tel bien
essayons de faire en sorte que dans les
dix mois dans les huit mois utiles qui
nous reste maintenant d'aller bien au
delà de ce qu'est le mouvement
aujourd'hui et stanislas guérini qui
m'aimait beaucoup d'ardeur je sais que
il faut changer la taille uniquement là
il va y avoir des il va y avoir de leur
désignation il va y avoir il pas se
représenter
et puis maintenant il doit il doit
jusqu'à la fin de l'année à agréger car
il tord de progrès tous ceux qui sont
jurés avaient changé d'étiquette merdy
cours pour aller à la présidentielle
je pense que c'est pas en marche et qui
à propane graal présidentielle je pense
que ce sera bien au delà nous ça veut
dire aussi un nouveau une nouvelle
appellation un nouveau nom de nouvelles
règles aux nominations sais pas si on va
parler de votre région va revenir aux
régionales c'est que 68 votre région
est ce que vous regrettez qu'il n'y ait
pas eu d'accord de second tour entre
marie-guite dufay denis thuriau ya ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui on sait plus bien
comment ça se passe quand on est ma
chronique qui est mon cas en marche au
les seuils de 2/3 de travailler avec
tous ceux quand on pense qu'ils
partagent le progrès et qui souhaitent
prendre les bonnes idées là où elles
sont donc nous avons d'abord pendant le
premier tour
madame du félin ne nous a jamais adressé
la parole jamais parlé elle a dit
qu'elle parlait à sa gauche
elle a parlé à sa gauche au soir du
premier tour
je les ai rencontrés sur un plateau
l'emea me le rappeler au téléphone dit
maintenant voilà bravo
beau score 24 en 2015 26 aujourd'hui
j'avais contribué à sa victoire en deux
en 2015 d'ailleurs très bien voilà ce
que vous souhaitez parler avec nous ce
qu'on peut discuter avec vous parce que
ya plus de risques front national le
front national qui était à 31 est à 23
vous voyez à madrid je réponds vous avec
les verts 26les vers 10 36 plus en plus
le temps des cerises qui font quatre à
côté de 40% de voix potentielles le fond
on peut pas monter au delà d'un n'y a
plus de risque front national d'ailleurs
je me félicite qu'il n'y ait pas demain
de telus front national en bon bien le
président y aura des élus dans le sud
dans les raisons les conseils régionaux
deux présidents tout à fait bon bien
président élu a priori dans ses cours à
batna le second tour a vendu faire
considère qu'elle n'a pas besoin de nous
elle m'a carrément fermé la porte au nez
en disant non je ne parle pas des clowns
parle qu'à ma famille comme pas le cas
ma gauche très bien je lui réponds donc
vous préférez avoir huit élus
communistes et huit élus verts que dix
ou douze ou quinze élus avec nous rdp il
en marche au leem dit oui tout à fait
bon c'est son choix à partir du moment
où elles pensent que la gauche et les
écologistes sont plus efficaces pour
faire barrage au rassemblement national
l'orage il est fait là haut que
l'arrivée quand marthe le barrage il est
fait aujourd'hui de lui signale que ça
tient pas à madame du fait que le front
national recule
ça tient l'action emmanuel macron c'est
sous ce président parmi les trois
derniers présidents que les rênes recul
il recule de 7 à 8 points
on nous a dit penser les élections
régionales emmanuel macron c'est des
gens c'est des élus de droite et de
gauche converti seulement d'affilée
monte vous auriez dit c'est l'action des
manuels matheron qui fait monter le pen
parce qu'il veut comme adversaire alors
là de ne fait pas le poids vert ça
surtout surtout pas donc villa emmanuel
macron avec la cfa gagneront les
présidents de gauche une fois son
gréement nationale son adversaire
principal
il l'a désigné comme tel et sous son
mandat à cette élection
le rassemblement national best 8 points
donc s'il avait monté une heure dix
voiliers voyez j'entends bien ici mais
hamid de droite de gauche c'est de le
regarder voilà ma france qui se passe il
fait monter le front ça les ennuie qui
baisse de ca c du lourd nouvelle aussi
celles ayant de solides ennuis il le
fait donc apprenez vous il n'y a pas de
risque aucun risque avéré je vois pas
pourquoi on se priverait demain d'avoir
dix élus et non des moindres qui
représente le maquereau nismo conseil
régional de bourgogne
juste pour finir sur un bourgogne
franche comté christian jacob il demande
le retrait de la liste de la majorité
présidentielle parce qu'il dit qu'il
faut éviter un risque de gouvernance
avec l'extrême gauche qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette demande payera pas de
l'extrême gauche n'auront pas d'extrême
gauche hyrule il y aura de l'explosion
et autres christian jacob ne met pas que
christian jacob ne nous donne pas de
leçons surtout de démocratie ni de
conduite morale politique le connaît
bien depuis très nombreuses années la
façon dont il a effacé sans dire un mot
l'alliance entre monsieur platret vu
debout la france montre bien que lui est
capable de toutes les avancées dans ce
sens là mais qu'il faudrait en plus
donner des leçons aux autres alors ses
leçons de morale je ne les entend pas
moi je sais qu'il n'ya pas de risque
démocratique en région bourgogne
je souhaite qu'il y ait des marcheurs et
des gens des macros nist qu'ils soient
élus au conseil régional
nous le faisons toute quiétude en toute
sérénité il faut se battre pour que les
scores ne recule pas au deuxième tour
parce qu'il pourrait y avoir un effet il
reste quelques heures pour conclure des
alliances de liste est ce qu'il ya des
des régions dans lesquelles les listes
la république en marge qui peuvent se
maintenir vont fusionner ou s'allier
avec d'autres
je crois que les listes la république en
marche ont tendu la main et là où
c'était possible partout et personnes
assises et apparemment elles ont été
refusées parce qu'on voit comment est ce
que vous êtes les voitures refusé parce
que les gens ont compris qu'il voulait
qu'il voulait être élu sans les
marcheurs bien entendu et je n'entends
pas ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils sont en
situation de force aujourd'hui est que
il rêve toujours de revenir à ce que me
disait il à refaire patrick kanner au
bon vieux clivages go clivage gauche
droite qui pensent qu'il va se rétablir
comme ça demain et qui a conduit à quoi
ce clivage gauche droite auquel aspire
monsieur retailleau monsieur k l'air ça
aboutit à des alternances terrils ça
pour dix annés instillant stérile on
voit bien que l'alternance avec emmanuel
macron il n'a pas été stérile parce que
je pourrai si j'avais la matinée vous
faire l'ensemble des réformes que nous
avons réalisé on va pas aller on n'a pas
la matinée malheureusement a parlé de la
région sud provence alpes côte d'azur où
le rassemblement national est en mesure
de pouvoir emporter la région
l'échec de la stratégie de jean castex
pas du tout pas du tout champ castex
d'abord jean castex a répondu à la
demande du président sortant c'est par
jean castex qui a dit on va aller vous
aider c'est le président sortant qui a
demandé au gouvernement en faire
supporter rigole un moment donné de
faire campagne avec eux jean castex a
répondu d'accord nous allons avec vous
ce qu'on aurait pu faire au deuxième
tour parce que vous imaginez bien moi je
vous dis parce qu'ici en bourgogne
france comté avec 13 14%
le front national avait été à 31 madame
dufy à 17 nous ne serions immédiatement
retiré la question n'est pas là elle ce
n'est pas là là il ya un risque avéré de
front national sortant c'est derrière
donc c'est je trouve normal
moi j'ai toujours été un adepte je dis
pas
du front républicain rappelons comme on
veut enfin de ceux qui paient
aujourd'hui faire une coalition de
républicains de la république que je
connais et à laquelle j'adhère
ce serait une bonne chose voilà alors
donc ya pas eu de région chez mais il me
semble que si la vue des régions où
c'était possible à la fois de gagner de
gagner et de et ailleurs j'ai vu que ils
appliquent eux la forissier a demandé un
marché nos deux tirs et voyez où c'était
nicolas forissier c'est le candidat de
la droite en centre val de loire marc
raynaud quant à la majorité socialiste
ont accompli d'alliance vous allez aussi
d irriguer des alliances qui aurait pu
être possible en bretagne en pays de la
loire et délits qui ne se feront pas
leur en bretagne vous accueillez vous a
pas échappé qu'il s'agit d'un cobra
froch fera pas les choses que j'ai envie
il est là encore là bon là encore le
risque de l'extrême droite est nul le
jeu de l'extrême droite et n'est donc
que chacun veut allier les sous ses
couleurs on vire les douars comment est
ample edwards en peignoir même chose
mena
la président à la présidente sortante
eux et moins pour assurer sa victoire
elle pu assurer sa victoire ici c'est
vrai que nous n'avons pas fait françois
de rugy n'a pas fait puis de le voir le
score qui pouvait escompter pour pouvoir
peser dans la décision
il aurait fallu que nous soyons à niveau
beaucoup plus a le plus bas que prévu
trois pales bas incitent les sortants à
dire à vous tourner le web pour le dogue
là on va terminer en parlant de ces
dysfonctionnements vous en avez un peu
parlé dont l'envoi de la propagande
électorale gérald darmanin sera
auditionné demain matin par la
commission des lois du sénat à 8 heures
le ministère de l'intérieur savait qu'il
y avait des problèmes dit françois noël
buffet le président de la commission des
lois est ce que le gouvernement a fauté
non je peux non il ya déjà eu des vrais
dysfonctionnements je vous le dit chez
moi n'a pas reçues il est le pont c'est
vrai alors on peut dire aujourd'hui que
le service public c'est vrai que quand
tu étais la poste qui est d'un seul
service public depuis les lois les lois
européennes ont changé je dis pas
qu'elles ont changé en mal elles ont
amélioré le sort des français doit bien
bien des cas y compris dans la
vaccination aujourd'hui mais là le fait
qu'il faille passer par l appel d'offres
conduit à ce genre de dérives qu'il faut
anticiper qu'il faut éviter qu'il faut
sanctionner
elle en fait elles n'ont pas été
anticipées non mais les préfets ont été
ont été ils ont fait des rappels ils ont
fait des rappels bien entendu
ils ont fait du tard sans doute parce
que ça s'est révélé très peur moi par
exemple j'ai attendu jusqu'au dernier
jour les documents je pensais qu'ils
allaient arriver
donc je n'ai pas appelé tous les jours
le préfet pour dire les et pendant que
vous dites il faut sanctionner comment
on sanctionne la le marché il a été
passé pour quatre ans avec l'entreprise
en question est ce qu'il faut le
remettre en cause
je pense qu'il faudrait mettre en cause
le couple alors la bonne tenue du
prestataire que j'ai vue totalement
défaillant il ya les raisons de le
mettre en cause oui à la question si
c'est la dernière question je vous
posais une question un peu décalé est ce
que emmanuel macron votera xavier
bertrand dimanche prochain est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il le dise publiquement
écoutez leurs amplis tracé ce qu'il a
dit oui mais brésil en la république
vote au touquet très bien que tout est
ok alors je sais pas ce que alors je
sais que là je sais que là je veux dire
je sais que la république en ondes en
art chez nous et man votera pour xavier
bertrand à l'appel potasser skippy
l'année prochaine les équipes de xavier
bertrand voteront par emmanuel macron ce
sera le mot de la fin c'est cesser votre
espoir je pense qu'un sport c'est la
certitude c'est différent on est amis on
va finir soir était notre invité ce
matin merci beaucoup de ses fans se
retrouvent jeudi pour parler notamment
des pays de la loire et on regarde la
une d'ouest france avant de se quitter
ses fans c'est l'abstention et cette
question pourquoi un tel désengagement
citoyen c'est à la une de ouest france
ce matin merci messieurs
[Musique]